The Avengers descend on Hollywood for
their epic premiere plus is Katy Perry
hinting she's back with ex Orlando Bloom
and his Blake Shelton recruiting Luke
Bryan to officiate a wedding guys I've
officially survived two weekends at
Coachella I'm sick of talking about it
and you're probably sick of hearing
about it but it was a good time but you
know what else looked like a blast last
night's infinity war premiere the cast
of the latest Avengers movie assembled
on to the purple carpet for the world
premiere none of them saw the movie
until last night and et was there for
all the action and here are three of my
favorite moments from the star-studded
carpet number one spider-man himself Tom
Holland brought his family including two
of his brothers and his mom Nicola who
was a bit camera shy but I thought was
pretty darn cute so take a look
was it getting them ready for tonight
you say like twenty one's an old man no
you might need your mom getting dressed
what do you think
and her word is kind of final you know
okay one less what's it like having a
superhero son speaking of family Chris
Pratt didn't bring his son Jack but the
little guys got a movie date with his
dad real soon how long till you let your
son see this movie oh I think we'll
probably oh next weekend well you you'll
take him the next yeah I'll take next
weekend now what happens when he's
watching you up there on the big screen
does it freak him out not at all no it's
it's kind of nice I mean he's been he's
been on sets enough I think he
understands he's eight he's smart he's a
smart little guy in with these you know
he doesn't have a world against which to
weigh his reality it might be weirder if
he would have bring some of his friends
with him or something but he just knows
that dad's an actor and this is and he
understands that he's I'm an actor and
we're all actors but he gets just like
me gets lost in the story you know
meanwhile I got lost in Scarlett
Johansson's eyes last night she made her
11 month relationship with SNL's colin
jost red carpet official guys but
months later and I still did not see
this ship coming but it is a thing and
the avengers premiere was a special date
night for the new couple of all um
common once gave me a really great
t-shirt this is the first time you guys
have done a red carpet together how was
it what is it like was it weird
unveiling that moment bad you know get
some laughs in and joy I'm just excited
to share this experience with them
because I'm so excited to see the film I
haven't seen it before
well that was adorable what do you guys
think you guys like seeing scarlet and
Colin together they're clearly still
going strong but like I said they're
coupling was a bit of a head-scratcher
for me but you know what then again
someone's Blake Shelton and Gwen Stefani
when they started dating I was like huh
and now look at them they are hotter
than ever and so in love and it actually
sounds like Blake already has one
decision to make about his future with
Gwen in Vegas your buddy Luke Bryan told
us that he wanted to officiate your
wedding too when if it happened but if
you wanted to be real maybe you should
get this is like a real my husband's
like wait I wanted to like be real like
it's like because you have officiated
weddings so like three of them are real
and then a couple of them it's not even
a legitimate country artist much less
lack of somebody that can marry people I
couldn't say what I wanted to say like a
beast
Oh like no you played piano you're here
to have this after party in Vegas I
didn't know you could play like oh yes
we did hang out we partied in Vegas and
performed it was there Kelly
Gwyn partied wasted yeah just destroyed
Kelly threw up I actually literally
ended up at wheel of fortune spot
dreaming up in her shirt pocket
I did not well we'll see what
shenanigans Kelly gets into tonight
because our girl turns up 36 today
happy birthday kill but about Luke's
offered to officiate Blake and Gwen's
wedding as you guys saw we were also
with Luke at American Idol so what does
he have to say about being denied by
Blake Blake literally just told us he
said you couldn't officiate his wedding
a few you know what of all the smart of
all the that may be the smartest thing
he's ever done Luke and Blake clearly
love busting each other's chops and
Blake have some ammunition now since
idols live elimination show came in a
close second to the voice last night
still 21 year old Texas native Kade
Feiner is who America couldn't resist
the Idol contestants scored a spot in
the top ten and maybe just maybe even in
judge Katy Perry's heart one guy I love
is Kade I love Kade Katie you're caught
up in the magic we can see it I've loved
watching you flirt with some of the guys
no real is the flirting well I mean when
you're a star and you're a gentleman a
gentleman star and you have that that
appeal you know that appeal that makes
everybody flustered it really works in
your favor ha could this happen
yes Katie's like that she's totally
could have been spoken for Matt and I
speak for myself and I'm very happy
you're spoken for right now yeah girl
where say oh right by one
are you a mrs. Broome I saw
no I'm not a mrs. Broome hold up dude
Katie just come from she's back with
Orlando Bloom I mean they split into
February 2017 after dating for a year
but then do you guys remember last month
she got a little flirty commenting on
his shirtless post on the gram writing
hey I was actually looking for a
washboard to do me laundry on plus a
source did tell ET the exes plan to give
their love a second chance so hold on in
the comments if you think Katie or
Orlando should go for it again I
personally think they're cool together
wait did I say cool I'm a hot
[Music]
well we're gonna keep an eye on those
two which means you should probably make
sure you're subscribed to our channel so
you don't miss another daily day and
we'll be back tomorrow with another one